wir kommen damit bis zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
in diesem wird über das verbot der
information für den
schwangerschaftsabbruch und diskutiert
grund ist es gibt ein gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung die den entsprechenden
paragrafen 219
aufheben möchte
dass dieser paragraf ist schon seit
längerem ja in der diskussion da geht es
darum dass vorher es keine so genannte
werbung für schwangerschafts abbrüche
geben durfte das bedeutete dass ärzte
zum beispiel auf ihrer webseite nicht
schreiben durften dass die
schwangerschaftsabbrüche
durchführen die union hat dann mit der
spd in der großen koalition lange
darüber diskutiert damit war man aber
letztendlich mit dem konsens der dann
geschaffen wurde auch nicht zufrieden
und marco buschmann bundesjustizminister
spricht jetzt dazu liebe zuschauerinnen
liebe zuschauer
vor ziemlich genau 30 jahren im frühling
1992 arbeiteten abgeordnete der spd
fraktion und abgeordnete der fdp
fraktion an einem gruppenantrag dieser
gruppen antrag hatte die veränderung des
damaligen paragrafen 218 des
strafgesetzbuches zum gegenstand und er
enthielt bereits alle wesentlichen
eckpunkte denn noch heute geltenden
beratungslösungen er setzte sich durch
in einem verfahren von insgesamt sieben
anträgen und wenige zeit später ist
dieses papier in einem gesetzentwurf
überführt worden der dann auch die
mehrheit im haus fand und das ist bis
heute das geltende recht warum erwähne
ich das hier immer wieder wird falsch
behauptet die entscheidung die wir heute
treffen über 219 a sei eine
respektlosigkeit oder gar unterhöhlung
des lebensschutzes konzeptes von 218 und
dazu möchte ich zwei dinge sagen uns
muss niemand den respekt vor diesem
historischen kommt promise lehrern es
waren unsere politischen vorgänger die
ihn geschmiedet und vorbereitet haben
zweitens es
ist eine juristische eine politische und
eine historische wahrheit dass paragraph
218 des strafgesetzbuches und § 209 10 a
nichts aber auch gar nichts miteinander
zu tun haben das ist keine
beeinträchtigung des lebens
schutzkonzept ich bitte diese wahl zu
akzeptieren
das worum es
sollte eigentlich geht kann man an der
lebenswirklichkeit erkennen und stellen
sie sich dazu bitte eine junge frau vor
die spanner ist die in erwägung zieht
diese schwangerschaft zu unterbrechen da
stellen sich sehr schwierige fragen und
es gibt im regelfall ein großes
bedürfnis nach orientierung nach
information und in unserer digitalen
wirklichkeit führt dieses bedürfnis doch
natürlich in sehr vielen fällen ins
internet weil dort eine gefühlte
anonymität und privatheit herrscht und
deshalb die schwelle dort nach
informationen zu suchen doch erst mal
niedriger ist als ich einem dritten
vielleicht einem fremden menschen
anzuvertrauen das ist die wirklich das
ist die lebenswirklichkeit und die
rechtslage dort die sieht heute wie
folgt aus im internet erlauben der jedem
verschwörungstheoretiker jeder fake news
schneider jeden unsinn über
schwangerschafts abbrüche zu verbreiten
aber qualifizierte ärztinnen und ärzte
als hüter der wissenschaft der fakten
der sachlichkeit und der aufklärung den
verbieten wie eher sachliche
informationen bereitzustellen das ist
doch absurd
es solle um gerechtigkeit und es ist die
konsequenz aus 219 und deshalb schaffen
wir ihn ab meine damen und herren
drei sorgen
möchte ich an dieser stelle nehmen weil
das ja wirklich eine ernsthafte debatte
ist die wir führen müssen die erste
sorge möchte ich noch mal sagen diese
rechtsänderung hat keine auswirkungen
auf das leben schutzkonzept von
paragraph 218 des strafgesetzbuches
zweitens die gefahr
abstoßender irreführender werbung
besteht nicht denn wir haben in unserem
entwurf
das heilmittelwerbegesetz so erweitert
dass es auch schwangerschafts abbrüche
die nicht medizinisch indiziert sind mit
umfasst das heißt die strengen regeln
des high mittel werbe gesetzes gelten
auch hier und das berufsrecht der ärztin
und ärzte gebietet ohnehin nur sachlich
zu informieren und keine reißerische
werben
und eine dritte sorge möchte ich nehmen
die auch immer wieder geäußert wird geht
es darum unter führte dazu dass ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch dadurch
wahrscheinlicher wird aber darum geht es
gar nicht wir wollen dass eine frau wenn
sie es möchte
informierter entscheiden kann und das
sollte in einer aufgeklärten
gesellschaft eine selbstverständlichkeit
sein meine dame
einen letzten gedanken möchte ich sagen
weil wir in unseren gesetzentwurf auch
für die wenigen aber schwerwiegenden
fälle wo es schon zu einer verurteilung
kam eine rehabilitierung lösung
aufgenommen haben die entscheidung haben
wir uns nicht leicht gemacht denn das
ist immer ein eingriff in die
gewaltenteilung aber es geht hier um
wenige fälle und das ist glaube ich
deshalb richtig und wichtig weil wir die
verurteilten ärzte und ärzte nichts auf
dem gnadenweg beim bundespräsident
zwingen wollen sie sollten nicht um
gnade bitten müssen sondern wir sollten
das problem aus der welt schaffen wir
hätten es schon im letzten bundestag
führen können der gesetzgeber hätte
schon handeln können die mehrheit hat
die kraft die die alte koalition nicht
hatte hat dazu jetzt die fortschritts
koalition verzichten
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann hat
hier den gesetzentwurf verteidigt
damit frauen die sich zu einem
schwangerschaftsabbruch entscheiden
möchten es sich oder das überlegen sich
besser informieren können die
unionsfraktion hat einen antrag
eingereicht in dem sie fordert den
schutz des ungeborenen kindes
beizubehalten sondern sie es und für die
unionsfraktion spricht jetzt nina warten
herr präsident lieber kolleginnen
kollegen herr minister auch wenn sich
bemüht haben hier ein anderes bild
abzugeben es ist schon erstaunlich und
macht mich sprachlos ein stück weit mit
wie wenig sensibilität sie an das thema
ran gehen und in den letzten tagen
konnte man einiges einige äußerungen von
ihnen dazu auch lesen sie sprechen von
befreiungsschlag wird groß auf der
webseite der fdp angekündigt ein
befreiungsschlag für die frau und damit
zeichnet sie ein völlig falsches bild
der derzeitigen lage und das finde ich
schon verantwortungslos
in deutschland sichert das geltende
recht den zugang zu einem medizinisch
korrekten schwangerschaftsabbruch
innerhalb von zwölf wochen nach der
zeugung allein aufgrund der entscheidung
der schwangeren ohne jede
strafrechtliche risiko unabhängig von
der finanziellen situation und circa
100.000 frauen machen davon jedes jahr
gebrauch keine einzige hat ein
strafrechtliches risiko einzige
voraussetzung ist eine beratung dort
wird umfassend über hilfen und ansprüche
informiert aber eben auch über das
lebensrecht des kindes anschließend
liegt die entscheidung allein bei der
frau diese regelung meine damen und
herren stellen wir nicht in frage aber
aber wir sind auch klar der meinung dass
es keine zusätzliche werbung braucht bei
ihrem gesetzentwurf geht es keineswegs
nur um information auf den praxis
webseiten auf die die schwangere nur
stößt wenn sie gezielt danach sucht da
sind ihre beispiele liebe kollegen der
ampel fraktion und die
gesetzesbegründung schlicht nicht
ehrlich wenn sie nur das wollen dann
legen sie doch
dann legen sie doch auch einen
gesetzentwurf vor der auch nur das
ermöglicht die geplante streichung von
219 ermöglicht anders als sie heute
wieder behaupten viel mehr zum beispiel
werbung in den sozialen medien anzeigen
und plakate sie richten sich nicht
reißerisch aber aktiv an die zielgruppe
und das sehen wir genau in ländern ohne
werbeverbot werben kliniken bei dem der
abbruch am günstigsten oder am
schnellsten geht und bei wem die
atmosphäre am freundlichsten ist und das
ist nach unserer auffassung mit dem
verfassungsrechtlichen schutz des
ungeborenen unvereinbar
ein schwangerschaftsabbruch ist keine
normale ärztliche heilbehandlung er
beendet einmaliges individuelles
menschliches leben und dass das nicht
verharmlost werden und auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht fordert dass
das gespür für das lebensrecht des
kindes im allgemeinen bewusstsein
erhalten bleiben muss werbung ist mit
den grundrechten und mit der würde des
ungeborenen nicht vereinbar werte
kollegen der regierungsfraktionen wir
liegen nicht auseinander beim blick auf
die schwangere frau jeder kann
nachempfinden dass eine ungewollte
schwangerschaft einem massiven konflikt
auslösen kann in einer solchen situation
ist es absolut selbstverständlich dass
sie sich als erstes im netz informiert
meine these ist allerdings dass sie jede
medizinische information über die
verschiedenen varianten von
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen und auch die
liste der bundesärztekammer mit den
praxen und kliniken mit wenigen klicks
im netz findet und wo es ihnen
eigentlich da genau fehlt sagen sie auch
nicht klar und es gibt natürlich jede
möglichkeit sich unmittelbar beim arzt
über alle details zu informieren indem
man zum beispiel dort anruft sie tun so
als selbst da irgend ein tabu und es ist
doch unsinn außerhalb von wert und gibt
es keinerlei limit bei der information
und
trotzdem sind wir in unserem eigenen
antrag auch offen dafür den umfang der
sachlichen informationen auf der
webseite der ärzte zu erweitern wo wir
auseinander liegen werte kollegen der
ampel ist beim blick auf das ungeborene
und dass dieser wichtige aspekt in ihrer
argumentation kaum eine rolle spielt ist
für mich unfassbar
sie weichen dieser frage auch heute in
den reden und anträgen aus das kind
kommt darin nicht vor oder sie sprechen
bloß von schwangerschafts gewebe aber
sagen wir doch mal wie es ist von anfang
an sind alle genetischen anlagen
festgelegt von anfang an gibt es eine
bruchlose kontinuierliche entwicklung
und das bundesverfassungsgericht hat es
auf die formel gebracht das ungeborene
entwickelt sich von anfang an als mensch
und nicht erst zum menschen und daraus
folgen grundrechte des ungeborenen und
diese müssen auch bei der wahrung der
alleinigen entscheidung der frau dann
natürlich berücksichtigt werden es
erfordert ein schutzkonzept zugunsten
des kindes mit der beratung und mit dem
verbot von werbung noch kurz ein paar
gedanken zur situation der ärzte drei
wichtige punkte erstens viele ärzte
führen aus gewissensgründen keine
abbrüche durch das spiel 219 a überhaupt
keine rolle 2 es ist klar und ohne jeden
graubereich geregelt welche
informationen auf den webseiten der
ärzte zulässig sind unklar ist die
regelung bisher nicht viel mehr wird sie
erst durch ihren gesetzentwurf unklar
und drittens eine aktive ansprache von
patientinnen ist auch heute schon
möglich meine damen und herren kurzum
wir sind bereit für gezielte
verbesserung eine streichung und 219 a
lehnen wir aber ab vielen dank
die rede von in jena wagen war das aus
der unionsfraktion ich habe es eben
schon angedeutet ist gab in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode in der
großen koalition einen minimalkonsens
dass man gesagt hat man kann zwar als
arzt informieren aber nicht über das wie
sondern dass man einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch anbietet für die
spd-fraktion spricht hier ist kam
entwickeln
demokratischen parteien sehr geehrte
damen und herren gerade bin ich versucht
kurz innezuhalten auf zu schauen und
diese situation zu genießen denn dies
ist der moment für den so viele frauen
jahrzehntelang auf die straße gegangen
sind dies ist der moment für den so
viele ärztinnen und ärzte gekämpft haben
dies ist der moment in dem wir endlich
in das parlamentarische verfahren zur
streichung von 219 aus dem
strafgesetzbuch eintreten dies ist der
moment der uns frauen ein stück weit die
hoheit über ihre körper zurückgeben wird
es ist ein schöner moment
die bis jetzt nicht nachvollziehen
können warum dies ein schöner moment ist
denen sei folgendes gesagt
219 trat am 26
mai 1933 in kraft und ist ein paragraf
des ns unrechts regimes
[Applaus]
es ist eine regelung die vorgeschoben
nach außen zum ziel hatte dafür zu
sorgen dass schwangerschafts abbrüche
nicht verharmlost und kommerzialisiert
werden
tatsächlich ist diese regelung aber eine
manifestation des patriarchalen und
frauenfeindlichen naziregimes
tatsächlich hatte diese regelung zum
ziel
frauen durch den mangel an informationen
dazu zu bringen nicht abzubrechen und es
ihnen deutlich zu erschweren
219 er ist damit ein gutes beispiel
dafür dass überall dort wo rechte
parteien an der macht sind frauenrechte
eingeschränkt werden
und das ist erschreckend
dass es 89 jahre gedauert hat bis wir
diesen missstand beheben können denn
schon längst ist klar dass 219 arno zu
drei dingen führt erstes die
kriminalisierung von ärztinnen und
ärzten die frauen in notsituationen
beistehen zweitens dass die medizinische
versorgungslage in deutschland für
frauen sehr sehr schlecht geworden ist
und drittens dass frauen aufgrund des
mangels an information oder über den
abbruch keine freie und differenzierte
entscheidung treffen können
denn bei 219 euro geht es eben nicht um
werbung sowie das leider immer wieder
von der union suggeriert wird sondern um
informationen und nein das ist auch kein
kleiner sondern ein großer unterschied
wir frauen werden endlich zugang zu
allen informationen haben die wir
benötigen um eine entscheidung fällen zu
können wer führt abbrüche durch und
welche methoden sind dabei möglich das
sind die relevanten fragen die ich als
frau in einer solchen situation
beantwortet haben möchte und endlich
dürfen wir das auch ärztinnen und ärzte
sagen und nicht irgendwelche youtube
stars für die diese regelung nämlich
nicht gilt
wer klaut
wer glaubt dass die streichung von 219
dazu führen wird dass ärztinnen aus
einmal zu reißerischer werbung in bezug
auf schwangerschafts abbrüche neigen
werden der kennt sich außerhalb des
strafgesetzbuches meiner meinung nach
nicht gut aus nicht nur das gesetz gegen
den unlauteren wettbewerb steht
reißerischer werbung in diesem bereich
entgegen auch die berufsordnungen der
landesärztekammern
um aber trotzdem
dass die rechtliche situation lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen um aber
trotzdem jeden rechtlichen zweifel
auszuräumen werden wir mit diesem
gesetzesentwurf auch das
heilmittelwerbegesetz anpassen das hat
der minister schon gesagt und den
anwendungsbereich auch schwangerschafts
abbrüche ausweiten dieser
gesetzesentwurf ist daher über jeden
zweifel erhaben und
dieser in den raum gestellte vorwurf
gegenüber den ärztinnen und ärzten die
in deutschland abbrüche durchführen ist
nicht nur absurd sondern meiner meinung
nach auch respektlos
daher möchte ich
daher möchte ich meine redezeit auch
nutzen um hier diesen ärztinnen und
ärzten danke zu sagen danke dass ihr uns
frauen die auf eure hilfe angewiesen
sind bei steht stellvertretend dafür
danke christina hände die durch ihre
prozesse vor gericht
das problem noch mal deutlicher in die
öffentlichkeit getragen hat danke an dr
bettina gabbe und dr verena beyer aus
berlin die klar benannt haben dass der
kampf gegen 219 ein feministischer kampf
ist danke
danke an doktor detlef michel märsche
der sich standhaft geweigert hat die
sachlichen informationen auf seiner
website runterzunehmen und danke an
doktor friedrich der trotz seiner 75
jahre nicht mit seiner arbeit aufhört
weil sonst ein drittel der frauen in
bayern die einen abbruch vornehmen
wollen nicht mehr versorgt werden danke
dafür
es ist folgerichtig dass das unrecht das
ihnen durch die kriminalisierung
zugefügt worden ist wiedergutgemacht
werden muss es ist folgerichtig dass wir
durch den heute vorliegenden
gesetzesentwurf alle urteile die auf
grundlage von 219 gefällt worden sind
aufheben werden es ist folgerichtig zu
sagen in dem zur verfügung stellen von
informationen kann kein unrecht liegen
es tut uns leid
heute
spielen sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
unionsfraktion nein danke
weil ich komme mir zu meinem setzt
letzten paar sätzen und die sind mir
sehr wichtig heute ist ein guter tag das
ist ein schöner moment gewöhnen sie sich
daran wir gehen vorwärts niemals zurück
hiernach
carmen wegge hatte es hier in schönen
tag genannt heute wird allerdings noch
nicht über diesen gesetzentwurf
abgestimmt sondern wird nach dieser
ersten lesung in die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen und kommt dann
noch mal ins plenum wundern wird hier
darüber diskutiert nächster redner in
dieser debatte ist nun thomas als
rechtspolitischer spahni es gibt erst
eine kurzintervention aus den seiten der
unionsfraktion
es kommt immer nur vernünftiges von mir
denke ich noch frau kollegin weg ich
habe eine anmerkung ich hatte eigentlich
eine frage gehabt aber das kann man auch
denke ich in dieser kurzintervention
klären ich habe mir noch mal angeschaut
ich war bis zum einzug in den deutschen
bundestag
zirka zwei jahrzehnte strafrichter und
was wir in der achtzehnten wahlperiode
was der deutsche bundestag oder
achtzehnter wahlperiode hier beschlossen
hatten da ging es um dieses
strafrechtliche rehabilitierungsgesetz
wegen der diskriminierenden verurteilung
homosexueller straftäter in diesem
zusammenhang hat man auch beschlossen
dass diese urteile aufzuheben sind um
diese diskriminierenden diskutieren
entscheidungen zu beseitigen dass das
aus dem bundeszentralregister soweit
noch eingetragen getilgt wird weil das
war die grundlage des ganzen mann wie es
schon betont habe gesagt hat das war
schreiendes unrecht
sind sie der meinung dass die
verurteilung die kollegen oder
kolleginnen von mir in den letzten
jahren es waren ja nur wenige wegen
verstoßes gegen zwei 19 a stgb gemacht
haben schreiendes unrecht dargestellt
werden mit dem der deutsche rechtsstaat
nicht leben kann und weshalb ist diese
urteile aufzuheben sind der kollege
buschmann hat von der durchbrechung der
gewaltenteilung der jüngst in dieser
verfassung gesprochen sind sie der
meinung dass an dieser stelle die
gewaltenteilung durchbrochen werden muss
frage sie können antworten
ja
ja ich sage es nochmal kurz ich habe das
eigentlich meine rede beantwortet aber
ja wir gehen davon aus dass es
schreiendes unrecht ist weil es geht
hier um informationen und wer immer
information teilt und deswegen bestraft
wird das ist eine politische
entscheidung dass wir das also großes
unrecht einordnen und es ist eine
richtige
sobald die kurzintervention von axel
müller und die wiederum von carmen
becker und jetzt kommen wir zur nächsten
redner hier in der debatte thomas seitz
für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren kommen wir
zurück zur sachlichkeit
der vorgelegte gesetzentwurf redet von
reproduktiver selbstbestimmung als
euphemismus für die tötung ungeborener
kinder
wahrheitswidrig behauptet dass es
rechtsunsicherheit bei der zulässigkeit
öffentlicher
informationen über abtreibungen gebe
dabei ist eindeutig dass ärzte
öffentlich auch jetzt schon darüber
informieren dürfen ob sie abtreibungen
nur dürfen durch durchführen nur nicht
wie das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
unverrückbare grenzen gezogen zitat
rechtlicher schutz gebührt den
ungeborenen auch gegenüber seiner mutter
und weiter ein solcher schutz ist nur
möglich wenn der gesetzgeber ihr einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch grundsätzlich
verbietet und ihr damit die
grundsätzliche rechtspflicht auferlegt
das kind auszutragen
zur erfüllung dieser schutzpflicht
musterstaat ausreichende maßnahmen
ergreifen um einen angemessenen und
wirksamen schutz zu erreichen dies ist
der grundsatz des unter maß verbots
wesentlich für das schutzkonzept ist die
trennung zwischen beratung und
durchführung der abtreibung öffentliche
informationen über abtreibung durch
ärzte die diese selbst durchführen sind
mit dem schutzkonzept nicht vereinbar
und genau deshalb verboten es stimmt
einfach nicht dass § 209 10 a das
auffinden eines geeigneten arztes
erschwert und die medizinische
versorgung beeinträchtige
denn es dauert keine minute um im
internet die seite familienplanung die e
der bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung zu finden die seite
informiert umfassend egal ob zur
rechtslage beratungsschein oder methoden
der abtreibung und ihre kosten nach
postleitzahlen sortiert sind für das
gesamte bundesgebiet ärzte und kliniken
aufgeführt die abtreibungen anbieten man
findet nicht nur adresse telefon-
e-mail- und homepage sondern auch
angaben zur angebotenen methoden und zu
fremdsprachen egal ob persisch oder
swahili in baden württemberg gibt es ein
angebot zur abtreibung auch in diesen
sprachen die leichte verfügbarkeit der
informationen zeigt dass es in wahrheit
keinen zu beseitigenden missstand gibt
warum jedes land das sagt ein
erbarmungsloser offenheit der antrag der
linken ein antrag für den ich wirklich
dankbar bin natürlich nicht dankbar für
die ethischen abgründe die sich darin
auf tun aber wohl für seine
schonungslose ehrlichkeit offen wird
hier als regierungsziel gefordert mit
der abschaffung von paragraph 218
abtreibung bewegungs frei zu erlauben
also bis unmittelbar vor der geburt mehr
perversion des rechts ist kaum
vorstellbar der wille der koalition alle
strafurteile zum § 209 10 a generell
aufzuheben also bewusst auch alle fälle
von grob anstößig oder irreführender
werbung verdeutlicht dass es in wahrheit
auch ihr darum geht das verbot der
abtreibung in frage zu stellen nur sagt
man ist eben nicht so offen wie die
linken das nenne ich salamitaktik eine
abtreibung ist aber kein normaler
medizinischer eingriff sondern sie
beendet vorsätzlich menschliches leben
niemand unterstellt frauen die sich für
eine abtreibung entscheiden es sich
einfach zu machen aber wir als
gesellschaft dürfen eine abtreibung auch
nicht zu einfach machen so sexuellen
freiheit gehört auch sich
eigenverantwortlich vor einer
ungewollten schwangerschaften schützen
und der zugang zur empfängnisverhütende
mittel ist definitiv heute zu tage keine
hürde mehr in diskussionen mit schülern
war ich zuletzt entsetzt über die
aggression des bewusstseins für recht
und unrecht
für viele ist abtreibung nur
nachgelagerte empfängnisverhütung und
eine selbstverständlichkeit und das darf
die tötung menschlichen lebens niemals
sein bei um die 100.000 registrierten
abtreibungen jedes jahr brauchen frauen
mehr unterstützen um damit sie sich für
ihr kind entscheiden es braucht eine
grundgesetzwidrige förderung der
abtreibung sondern eine
willkommenskultur für kinder vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
meine damen und herren sie sehen es wir
zeigen hier auch schon ein bild aus der
ostseeküste in der nähe des weißen
häuser stranz findet ihr das treffen der
außenminister der g 7 staaten statt und
wir erwarten annalena baerbock unsere
aussenministerin dort zu einem statement
zu lange bleiben wir aber natürlich in
der debatte und dort spricht eine
weitere ministerin lisa paus
bundesfamilienministerin
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
bürger innen die streichung des
paragrafen 219 a ist längst überfällig
wer anders als die schwangeren sollte
entscheiden ob sie ein kind austragen
möchten oder können wer anders als
frauen sollte darüber entscheiden wann
und in welchen abständen sie kinder
bekommen und wer anders
und wer anders als mediziner innen
sollte diesen frauen bei stehen und sie
über einen abbruch informieren
es geht um fundamentale es geht um
existenzielle fragen um das
menschenrecht auf reproduktive
selbstbestimmung um das recht von frauen
über ihren körper zu entscheiden
und selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ist auch das recht
des kindes auf leben ein menschenrecht
spielen wir doch beide rechte nicht
gegeneinander aus alle statistiken
zeigen es ist die gute beratung die
frauen mut macht für ein leben mit einem
kind und nicht die androhung von strafe
und erst recht nicht die aktionen von
abtreibungsgegnern
die schwangere frauen vor
beratungsstellen belästigen und zu
kriminellen erklären
das sogenannte werbeverbot untergräbt
das recht von frauen auf körperliche
selbstbestimmung und ihr recht sich über
abtreibung zu informieren und das ist
schlicht zynisch dass ärztinnen dafür
strafverfolgung fürchten müssen mal
damit jahren es ist gut dass ihre
fahrkarten kaufen
frauen aber unsere ganze gesellschaft
brauchen rechtssichere lösung für alle
lebenswirklichkeiten und das
bundesfamilienministerium ministerin
freue ich mich riesig über den erfolg
der frühen hilfen die bundesstiftung
mutter und kind oder auch unsere
bundesinitiative hilfe und unterstützung
vor ungewollter kinderlosigkeit
reproduktive rechte sind leider nicht
selbstverständlich
sie geraten immer wieder unter druck das
zeigt jetzt auch der entwurf des us
supreme courts und auch in europäischen
nachbarländern deuten sich geschlechts
politische rohbeck sun
der fraktion rechts von uns allen
scheint das zu gefallen wäre gerade
hören konnten dieses gesetz und die
debatte heute haben eine wichtige
signalwirkung die bundesregierung diese
bundesregierung steht an der seite der
frauen und zu ihrem recht auf
körperliche selbstbestimmung
und deshalb deshalb wollen wir auch ein
zweiter schritt gehen und die regelungen
für den schwangerschaftsabbruch
außerhalb des stgb treffen um diese
hochkomplexen juristischen fragen zu
klären setzen wir eine kommission zur
reproduktiven selbstbestimmung ein so
wie sich frauen auf medizinische
leistungen verlassen dürfen wenn sie
sich für ein kind entscheiden sollen sie
künftig auf medizinische leistung
vertrauen können wenn sie sich gegen ein
kind entscheiden
das waren was sagt ab werk gehört
einfach nicht im strafrecht meine damen
und herren ich bin sicher
gemeinsam mit expertinnen und meinen
kollegen
justizministerium und vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium werden wir
gute antworten finden ich bitte sie und
ihre unterstützung ganz
die bundesfrauenministerin lisa paus war
dass die linksfraktion hat hier auch
einen antrag eingereicht in dem sie
voller den paragrafen 218 zu streichen
da geht es darum dass
schwangerschaftsabbrüche grundsätzlich
verboten sind teilt die reicheneck
spricht jetzt für die linke
nach über 90 jahren wird der nazi § 209
10 a mit dem frauen und ärztin den
entmündigt und drangsaliert werden bald
endlich der vergangenheit angehören
dafür sorgen wir jetzt
die bezeichnung werbeverbot ist aber
einfach nur widerwärtig untergräbt noch
heute den kampf der frauen für
körperliche selbstbestimmung
denn das ist doch der kern um den es
hier geht es geht nicht um werbung es
geht um neutrale und umfassende
informationen über einen medizinischen
eingriff frau kollegen sondern
zwischenfrage des grünen klubs zu der
kreationen
verlängert new south wales günter krings
aus der unionsfraktion hat eine
zwischenfrage ein paar kollegen ich bin
nur einer einzigen historisch sachlichen
punkt richtig stellen weil aber mehrfach
jetzt falsch genannt worden ist sind sie
bereit zur kenntnis zu nehmen dass der
vorgänger paragraf dieses werbeverbot
ist das hier heute jedenfalls deutlich
eingeschränkt werden soll nicht in der
nazi zeit entstanden ist soll in der
weimarer republik einer vorgänger
demokratie die sicherlich nicht perfekt
war wo demokratischen parteien
gestritten haben auch um solche themen
und dort ist er konzipiert worden ist in
der tat erst noch 33 ins gesetzblatt
gekommen aber konzipiert worden in der
weimarer zeit ein historisches faktum
sind sie bereit das zur kenntnis zu
nehmen
meine kollegin von der spd hat das schon
sehr gut dargestellt wie der kursverlauf
und
sehr interessiert der hat ja auch sehr
interessiert gelauscht habe ich erinnere
mich an ihren zwischenrufen habe ich
auch noch mal ganz genau dargestellt in
welchem geist dieser artikel entstanden
ist dieser paragraph umgesetzt wurde und
sie können die gerne nochmal anhören so
aber gut ich mache dann mal weiter wenn
ich dann nämlich höhere liebe cdu csu
oder sind zitate von ihnen man muss ja
nicht jede mode mitmachen und
abtreibungskliniken haben dann sowie
schönheitsklinik und gerade eben wieder
dann gibt es die zielgruppenspezifische
werbung dann frage ich mich ja welches
raum bin haben sie eigentlich denken sie
wirklich dass irgendeine frau sagt
mensch das ist ja mal eine spannende
erfahrung so eine abtreibung jetzt mache
ich das oder mensch was für eine schöne
überraschung dann mache ich wohne
abtreibung glauben sie dass frauen so
denken ja ich merke schon alles klar sie
merken schon selbst wie absurd das
klingt ja die aktuelle
regelung der großen koalition ist ein
elend und wenn die cdu/csu dieses elend
des mit ihrem antrag auch noch fest
klopp will liebe kolleginnen dann sage
ich mal stellvertretend für die mehrheit
des hauses und der gesamtgesellschaft
die streichung von 219 a und ja das ist
richtig ist nur der erste schritt den
wir gehen müssen schwangerschafts
abbrüche die auf den wunsch der
schwangeren durchgeführt werden müssen
endlich entkriminalisiert werden auch
das eu-parlament und die
weltgesundheitsorganisation vor und
exakt das deswegen muss auch paragraf
218 endlich weg und deswegen brauchen
wir nicht nur eine kommission die
darüber diskutiert ob 218 feld sondern
wie und wir brauchen diese kommission
sofort doch aktuell steht nicht mal fest
wer darin wie arbeiten soll von der
einrichtung ganz zu schweigen deswegen
fordern wir in unserem antrag auch das
reproduktive gerechtigkeit endlich zum
regierungsstil erklärt wird damit wir
auch endlich vorankommen und mal zum
thema nachgelagerte verhütung wie das
gerade von der afg benannt wurde was ja
ich sag dazu wenig aber stellen sie sich
mal vor geworden jetzt erwarten dass
jedermann ja keine kinder will eine
vasektomie durchführen lässt das wäre
doch mal was erscheint aber auch ein
bisschen absurd absolut übergriffig aber
man erwartet ja schließlich von frauen
auch dass die hormone schlucken die
massive nebenwirkungen haben man
erwartet von frauen dass sie für die
pille danach eine demütige beratung über
sich ergehen lassen und eigentlich
erwartet man ehrlicherweise von frauen
auch dass sie noch die kondome dabei
haben um am ende mit irgendeinem typen
diskutieren zu müssen dass ich das ja
nicht so toll anfühlt wir sollten
vielleicht auch etwas brauchen ja
vielleicht sind dann goalie yann sommer
steine zwischen erlauben sie hatte
zwischen händel frau kollegin frau
kollegin erlaubten sie eine
zwischenfrage von frau von storch
war das sind 1 9 oder nur ein
stoßseufzer
vergütung ist doch schon die komplette
verantwortung der frau wertes forschung
tötungsmethoden für männern kaum gibt
und nach all dem kriminal sehen wir
brauchen auch noch und machen den zugang
zu schwangerschaftsabbrüchen so schwer
und teuer wie möglich frauen mit geld ja
die können zu einer weit entfernten
praxis fahren sich ein hotel erlauben
sie fahren notfalls für eine abtreibung
über die grenze aber stellen sie sich
mal vor 200 km wir verlassen die
aussprache an dieser stelle umschauen
richtung weißen haus
[Musik]
kommunalisiert werden
wie new cars the
millions of
the world
und deshalb ist es wirklich sehr gut
dass wir uns hier konzentrieren auf die
globale lebensmittelkrise wir können da
nur die spitze des eisbergs im
augenblick sehen wir wissen dass wenn
die klimakrise im sommer die welt trifft
das dann die lage noch schlimmer wird
deshalb hatten wir schon jetzt
vereinbart dass wir eine politische
antwort als g7 geben müssen die
industrialisierten staaten die
demokratien weltweit wir übernehmen
unsere verantwortung um diese krise in
angriff zu nehmen und schnell zu handeln
wir haben auch unsere eigenen
initiativen begonnen jeder weltweit ist
es aber auch wichtig schnell zu handeln
wir kommen dann nachher noch einmal
drauf zurück können wir die tisch
umfrage machen aber ich denke dass es
wichtig dass wir heute nicht nur
debattieren sondern sieben zu sagen als
die sieben länder verabschieden um zu
zeigen dass wir vorbereitet sind wir
wollen gegen diese nahrungsmittel krieg
vorgehen in denen putin weltweit an gz
vielen dank und melanie beginnt jetzt
mit dieser sitzung wir bedanken uns bei
den medien und wir werden uns dann
später sehen
[Applaus]
damit sind wir auch schon wieder zurück
in der debatte sie haben keine rednerin
verpasst nur den anfang von canan bayram
von 5 90 die grünen gehören in ihren
reihen ruhig im krankenhaus landen oder
im schlimmsten fall sterben der sichere
zugang zu
medizinischer versorgung ist
lebensschutz meine damen und herren und
deswegen ist es auch so scheinheilig
wenn die cdu/csu ihren antrag in ihren
antrag schreibt und sie haben es in
ihrer rede hier auch noch peinlicher
weise wiederholt frau kollegin ohne 219
a könne nicht sichergestellt werden dass
schwangerschaftsabbrüche künftig nicht
kommerzialisiert werden da frage ich sie
geht's noch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union das ist so
respektlos gegenüber den ärztinnen und
ärzten und das ist respektlos gegenüber
den frauen die diesen schutz brauchen
damit machen wir jetzt schluss meine
damen und herren wir von der
fortschritts koalition machen schluss
mit der unsachlichen
kriminalpolitik der cdu und schluss mit
der bevormundung von frauen wir stehen
für versorgungssicherheit und
selbstbestimmung und wären wir schon
einmal dabei sind freue ich mich auch
schon darauf dass wir uns als ampel noch
so vorgenommen haben erstens machen wir
schwangerschafts abbrüche zum teil der
ärztlichen ausbildung damit mehr
ärztinnen die abbrüche anbieten können
und frauen überall zugang dazu haben
zweitens werden wir die möglichkeiten
schaffen die kosten der schwangerschafts
abbrüche zu übernehmen und drittens
werden wir das system der
schwangerschafts abbrüche im strafrecht
auf den prüfstand stellen denn für uns
steht fest
selbstbestimmung darf kein verbrechen
sein meine damen und auch glauben sie
noch alle zwischen oder nachfrage und
braus und stolz
offensichtlich nicht die störche sind
vorbei
es ist quali storchen zeit wenn ich
darauf hinweisen
gut ich akzeptiere das ist also die fdp
fraktion wünscht eine kurze information
von storch sie haben jetzt die
möglichkeit sich zu äußern
vielen dank herr präsident dass sie die
intervention zu lassen ich habe eine
frage an frau brandi drehte sich an alle
die die hier für dieses abschaffung des
werbeverbots aufgerichtet haben aber sie
sind jetzt adressiert sie reden alle
über die frauen und das recht der frauen
in extension das einzige was bei ihm nie
vorkommt ist das ungeborene kind das
findet in ihrer gesamten debatte nicht
statt
und ich möchte gerne von ihm wissen ich
möchte gerne von ihnen wissen ab welchem
moment sie anerkennen dass das
ungeborene kind ein mensch ist das volle
menschenwürde hat dass ein lebensrecht
hat das leben darf und dass man nicht
mehr antasten darf sagen sie mir ab
welchem monat sie der meinung sind dass
eine abtreibung nicht mehr zulässig sein
soll bis wann
darf ein muss ein ungeborenes kind um
sein leben fürchten und ab wann nach
ihrer anschauung ist das leben des
ungeborenen kindes
lebenswert
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr präsident frau von
storch ich stelle fest dass sie das
thema immer noch nicht verstanden haben
und auch keinen wertvollen beitrag zu
dieser debatte liefern können insoweit
hätte ihre fraktionen ihnen das recht
einräumen können zu dieser debatte zu
diskutieren der beitrag ihres kollegen
seitz hat eigentlich das desinteresse
ihrer fraktion an einer vernünftigen
debatte an diesem punkt deutlich gemacht
und ihre kurzintervention waren nicht
dazu geeignet dass in ein anderes licht
zu rücken deswegen steht für meine
fraktion fest wir werden das thema
weiter sachlich bearbeiten und wir
wollen den lebensschutz
für alle beteiligten durch medizinische
informationen sicherstellen indem wir
den paragrafen 219 anstreichen
bildern vorlegen sie haben die frage
beantwortet das mag ihn
ja ich versuche alles zu erklären sie
hat sie hat geantwortet ob sie das mit
zufriedenheit oder nicht liegt nicht
mehr messen des kollegiums
dennoch einmal sie hat die frage
beantwortet im rahmen ihrer
möglichkeiten und ja sie hat ja waren
sie doch was er sagt und
dem von ihm und dem event und im rahmen
dieses verständnis ist insofern können
wir das nicht tun nächste gegnerin ist
die kollegin dorothee bär cdu/csu dazu
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich habe im vorfeld dieser
debatte mir überlegt dass uns sicherlich
heute im haus hier eine gewisse
ernsthaftigkeit 1 und das uns heute hier
auch im haus 1 zu überlegen was ist für
jede einzelne frau was es aber auch für
das ungeborene kind für das ungeborene
leben das wichtigste und es ist eine
debatte die auch wenn man seit vielen
vielen jahren ja schon seit jahrzehnten
hier am rednerpult stehen darf eine die
sehr sehr emotional ist und einige
keinen kalt lassen kann und wo es meines
erachtens auch keine einfachen lösungen
gibt und kein richtig und kein falsch
und deswegen war ich tatsächlich
schockiert entsetzt traurig sehr geehrte
frau kollegin wette mit welcher art und
weise sie hier aufgetreten sind
stellen und zu sagen ich genieße es ist
ein schöner moment
muss ich wirklich sagen schauen sie sich
jeder rede vielleicht in fünf jahren in
zehn jahren in 15 jahren noch einmal an
erklären sie vielleicht irgendwann haben
ihren kindern was sie heute hier
abgezogen haben es ist wirklich etwas wo
ich sagen muss das ist doch nicht der
geist den die seit debatte atmen sollte
und wir müssen uns doch auch immer
wieder klar machen wir uns heute zu
schaut uns schauen heute frauen zu
vielleicht mit drei kindern von denen
wir nicht wissen dass sie um überhaupt
diese drei kinder zu bekommen schon sehr
schwangerschaften hinter sich hatten und
schauen frauen die keine kinder bekommen
können ich habe vorher noch mit jemanden
gesprochen die mit 20 jahren das erste
mal das einzige mal auch abgetrieben hat
und jetzt in einer
kinderwunschbehandlung ist das ist sehr
emotional die frau und die uns heute
zuschauen wir schauen uns frauen so die
sternenkinder haben es schauen uns
frauen zu die vielen fehlgeburten hatten
die abtreibungen hinter sich haben die
vielleicht regenbogen kinder haben und
deswegen würde ich mich einfach freuen
wenn wir schon über diese debatte heute
sprechen auf der einen seite
vordergründig 219 aber wie es ja auch
deutlich wurde in vielen redebeiträgen
dass es eigentlich um den 218 er geht
das ein bisschen seriöser auch
verstanden gilt
und was mich auch stören
ihr leben diese frage bitte verlassen
sie die zwischenfrage aus der fraktion
jetzt nicht was mich auch wahnsinnig
stört ist dass sie es mit fortschritt
begründen mit selbstbestimmung mit
freiheit und dass sie so tun als ob wir
auch als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion die
frau nicht in den mittelpunkt stellen
das tun der nämlich und natürlich geht
es um selbstbestimmung und natürlich
geht es darum dass mir frau entscheiden
kann das kann sie aber und wir trauen
den frauen eben auch zu dass sie sich
selber entscheiden können nachdem sie
eine ordentliche beratung eben auch
hinter sich warten weil das können sie
doch auch nicht abstreiten so einer hoch
emotionalen situationen muss jemand die
möglichkeit haben mit jemanden
anzusprechen muss jemand die möglichkeit
haben eben auch begründet werden im
anschluss mit dem arzt jahr aber erstmal
eine neutrale beratung in einer
hochemotionalen phase meine kollegin
nina hagen hat für ausgesprochen
meine kollegin hat ja gesagt wie
notwendig das ist das eben auch immer
jemand an der seite der frau ist weil
die frau wird die entscheidung ihr
ganzes leben bei sich tragen egal ob sie
das kind austrägt oder nicht dass muss
man doch immer auch im hinterkopf haben
und ich möchte mich noch mal der meinung
auch von der kollegin wagen anschließen
und so müssen wir können doch so eine
debatte nicht führen in dem kein
einziges mitglieder ampel nicht auch
noch vom kind spricht und wir können
doch auch diese debatte nicht stören
wir können doch diese debatte nicht
führen wenn sich jetzt auch was die
strafgesetzbuch und ähnliches betrifft
wenn sich in der letzten hand
durchführen wollen das ist mit uns nicht
zu machen eine ärztin die von zellhausen
steht eine aktie die noch nicht mal
akzeptiert dass es ein embryo ist ein
werdendes leben jeder der mal schwanger
war jeder der erfährt dass sie schwanger
ist bei seiner frauen als sie bei einem
frauenarzt liegt ein ultraschall
bekommen und in der sechsten woche schon
bis herzschlägen vorschlagen wird schon
was da leben am wachsen ist und dann zu
sagen dass es nur ein zellhaufen und es
ist normaler eingriff wieder antritt
dass es mit uns auf keinen fall zu
machen
und niemals niemand regt so eine
entscheidung gleichzeitig fast niemand
würde ich sagen fast niemand wenn man
sich einige interviews diese woche
durchgelesen hat von jutta ditfurth und
ähnlichen meine zweite abtreibung war
die schönste das lass ich mal dahin
gestellt aber die mehrheit trifft sie
nicht leichtfertig und ich kann ihnen
nur sagen unterstütze sie uns ein antrag
wir wollen § 209 10 a nicht abschaffen
wir wollen ihn erhalten wir wollen ihn
verbessern wir wollen weitere
informationsmöglichkeiten für ärztinnen
und ärzte wir wollen ergebnisoffene
beratung wir appellieren an sie als
bundesregierung mit den ländern zu
sprechen dass es eben überall in allen
regionen auch als zehn ärzte gibt wir
wollen rechtliche voraussetzungen dass
auch die gesetzlich verordnete
verhütungsmittel übernommen werden und
ich freue mich tatsächlich auch über
eine seriöse weitergehende beratung
möchte aber abschließend kurz an die
beiden minister die heute gesprochen
haben sie bewusstlos letzter satz der
präsident der buschmann hat das ganze
heute ja sehr sachlich sehr down 12 219
hier besprochen sagt haus hat schon in
218 er ins spiel gebracht ich bin auf
die beratungen gespannt und hoffe dass
die bundesregierung das sind einer
seriösen art und weise macht bei uns ist
es wahnsinnig wichtig wären
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende dorothee bär hat
gesprochen noch ein bisschen arbeiten
also die beziehungen von fast einer
minute ist irgendwie nicht hinzunehmen
die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen die
fraktion
jetzt gibt es noch eine kurzintervention
aus den fraß der grünen fraktion ist
ohne chance ich muss feststellen dass
sie von der unionsfraktion kollegin bär
hat das jetzt gerade noch einmal sehr
deutlich gemacht aber auch die privaten
und auch in den letzten debatten das was
sie in den letzten jahren zu § 209 10 a
immer wieder gemacht haben noch mal zu
einer nochmal fokussiert haben zu einer
spitze zu treiben zu sagen das ist eine
permanente vermischung in diesem gerüst
wird von dem sie sprechen mit 218 der
justizminister die frauenministerin
haben es sehr deutlich gemacht das ist
tatsächlich einfach falsch dass sie das
behaupten hat damit zu tun dass sie dass
sie tatsächlich immer und immer wieder
auf das gleiche hinaus wollen und auch
in ihrer moralisierenden
emotionalisierenden rede mit
schuldzuweisung mit denen sie natürlich
die ganze zeit hier auch austeilen geht
es darum und das muss ich einfach
feststellen dass sie eines tun sie
prägen eine extreme misstrauenskultur
gegen frauen gegen die selbstbestimmung
von frauen und vor allen dingen gegen
die informationsfreiheit und das
berufsrecht von ärztinnen und an dieser
stelle möchte ich die frage an sie
stellen frau kollegin bea würden sie zu
ihrer frauenärztin oder zu ihrem
frauenarzt gehen und ihm ins gesicht
genau das was sie hier an
misstrauenskultur jeder ärztin jedem
arzt in diesem land der der versorgungs
des versorgungsauftrags den wir
gegenüber für ungewollt schwangere haben
jedes land hat diesen versorgungsauftrag
und es wird immer schwieriger die
versorgungslage sicherzustellen würden
sie einer ärztin
ihres vertrauens genau dieses misstrauen
was sie hier seit monaten und seit
jahren in diesem bundestag tragen würden
sie das einer person der sie an
vertrauen ihre gesundheit ins gesicht
sagen es würde ich wirklich gerne von
ihnen wissen
würden sie einer frau auch ins gesicht
sagen die ungewollt schwanger ist dass
sie das moralisch was sie hier auch
immer vortragen auch verurteilen würden
sie das tun
was sie können jetzt an bord
ehrlicherweise erlebe ich sie
moralisierend und nicht uns und auch
wenn sie es
und auch wenn sie ehrlicherweise nichts
angeht ich sage es ihnen trotzdem ich
habe ein hervorragendes sehr sehr gutes
verhältnis zu meinem eigenen frauenarzt
und er stimmt mir an dieser debatte und
insgesamt in dieser ganzen diskussion
voll und ganz zu
letzte rednerin in dieser debatte ist
die jubiläen kollegin leni breymaier spd
vielen dank herr präsident lieber
minister bußmann liebe ministerin haus
wir haben zusammen den koalitionsvertrag
verhandelt im bereich gleichstellung und
es war nicht so schnell klar wieder
punkt dass wir in dieser koalition den
paragrafen 219 ersatzlos streichen und
das ist gut so und wir haben
in der gleichen
verhandlungen verabredet dass wir zum
paragraf 218 und reproduktionsmediziner
kommission einsetzen werden die sich mit
diesen dingen befasst und sehr geehrte
frau kollegin bea wenn sie die rede von
heute nach der kommission gehalten
hätten hätte gepasst aber zum 29 10 hat
sie wirklich nicht gepasst
die ziele sind wichtig vahrenholt auch
in den debatten von der banalisierung
des schwangerschaftsabbruchs und
fehlende ernsthaftigkeit der debatte und
da sage ich mal da können sie von der
union sagen dass das ungeborene kind bei
uns ausgeblendet würde das ist einfach
dummes zeug schauen sie nicht durch ihre
konservative brille schauen sie die
realität von frauen die sich in einer
solchen konflikt situation befinden und
die eventuell vor einem
schwangerschaftsabbruch stehen wenn man
weil man ja als heute schon wieder so
viel gehört haben zum geschichtlichen
abriss bin habe ich noch mal
nachgeschaut die weimarer republik hat
bei schwangerschaftsabbrüchen die strafe
vom zuchthaus auf gefängnis gesenkt und
wurden dann wieder erhebliche
verschärfungen bis zur todesstrafe
vorgenommen und auch die ankündigung und
an reisende wieder unter strafe gestellt
das ist der faktor jetzt du dir fast
hundert jahre daran herum diskutieren
und ich bin froh dass wir jetzt den 219
endlich sprechen
wir haben damit bislang periode das
problem leider nicht lösen können in
unserer vor schwangerschaft zur
koalition sind bei der union da ziemlich
weit entgegengekommen das problem aber
nicht gelöst weil in der
bundesärztekammer in der liste finden
sich längst nicht alle klinik und alle
praxen die abtreiben in baden
württemberg mit 11 millionen
einwohnerinnen und einwohner sind gerade
mal 16 kliniken und praxen aufgeführt in
der uni stadt wie freiburg oder ulm
nicht eine einzige dh die frauen finden
eben nicht die informationen die sie
brauchen und achten und hören
was auf ihren homepages schreiben das
gehört ja auch noch dazu dass fragen
über die möglichkeit von narkose- und
betäubung zur kostenübernahme zur
nachsorge mitzubringen die unterlagen
und so weiter und so fort hier steht ist
nicht auf der homepage der
bundesärztekammer und das ist das
problem
und es geht nicht strom das hier
gebrauchte im werken soll für
schwangerschafts abbrüche das ist eine
böse unterstellung
rein gar nichts wenn die pumpe oder ob
diese praxis können sie bauen das ist
alles gibt's doch gar nicht es geht
darum dass wir den frauen die
informationen zukommen lassen wollen die
sie brauchen und wir wollen es
ungeborene leben schützen und zwar nicht
durch strafandrohung was wir brauchen
wir das ungeborene leben das ist
bezahlbarer wohnraum in entsprechender
größe ordentliches entgelt für die frage
brauchen gute kinderbetreuung
unsere unter damit schöpfen ungeborenes
leben von addons straße angehoben
[Applaus]
auch in einem kontext steht mit debatten
wie auf der ganzen welt geführt werden
in polen streiten die frauen um ihr
recht auf selbstbestimmung in den usa
streiten sie um ihr recht auf
selbstbestimmung auch hier streiten wir
nur da streiten wir nur darum hier
streiten wir aktuell nur darum ob ärzte
ihre patienten
informieren dürfen umsonst nichts und
deshalb ist es gut
[Applaus]
eine zwischenfrage aus der aktie
mit dem ende der rede hat sich auch die
frage an der zwischen frage erledigt mit
der aus so und das war dann hier diese
debatte sie doch in weiten teilen sehr
sachorientiert war aber doch bei diesem
thema hat man gemerkt dass es eben ein
emotionales thema ist dass viele auch
beschäftigt persönlich angreift wenn
denn hier im plenum eine andere als ihre
meinung vertreten wird das thema wird
wieder
hier im bundestag diskutiert nachdem es
in den entsprechenden ausschüssen auch
noch mal